modern life relies on huge amounts of
energy
but 80 percent of the world's power
comes from fossil fuels
and the sector emits the majority of
global greenhouse gases
without a drastic shift to alternative
sources
the catastrophic effects of climate
change will be felt everywhere
but which forms of energy are the most
sustainable and practical to accelerate
the green transition
vijay vivi swaran the economists global
energy and climate innovation editor
answers your questions
how much energy needs to come from
renewables to cut emissions
so the question of renewables
the answer is more
is better uh of course
renewables are not the only form of low
carbon energy so there's a a trap in the
question that's embedded i'd like to
take on what we need is uh zero carbon
energy or net greenhouse gas
negative ways of having an energy system
renewables are an important source of
that but nuclear energy which is often
overlooked or is controversial could
play a big role in the future as well
and we can imagine forms of
energy that can lead to
negative kinds of emissions if done
properly that are expensive at the
moment today that could also play a role
why isn't nuclear power used more widely
when it's a clean energy source
are strong nuclear
advocates in the world who say you can't
achieve
the net zero carbon goals set by the
paris climate accord without a
significant amount of the world's
electricity coming from nuclear which is
in effect carbon-free
but the problem is really political more
than technological and economic
political because there are strong
anti-nuclear movements in germany for
example in japan and a number of other
countries arising from a handful of
nuclear accidents fukushima which is
fundamentally
not a nuclear accident but was never
nevertheless traumatized the country
about the dangers of nuclear three-mile
island in america was an accident
several decades ago and of course
chernobyl in europe those are the
obstacles but if we could increase
nuclear power or at least retain its
share in global electricity production
it would definitely help because it is a
virtually zero carbon source of power
how can solar power be made more
efficient
in theory
all of humanity's needs can be met by by
solar power uh in a couple of hours the
earth receives more energy from the sun
than all of the energy used by mankind
in a year but that's a great theory the
practicality is the conversion rate of
that energy the capture conversion and
ultimately distribution is extremely
inefficient and so
we could improve the efficiency of solar
panels that could be done through better
materials
better chemistry lots of people are
working on this but also how we store
the energy because of course it's
intermittent sun only is out for part of
the day that is energy storage could be
improved hydrogen which is an energy
carrier it's like electricity you got to
make it from something some form of
energy
has a second property
that is it can also be used for
long-term storage so not just a few
hours of storage like batteries today on
the grid but multi-season storage you
could store when you have lots and lots
of hydro or lots of uh wind and then use
it during a
peak period some months later
and that's their experiments around the
world with this at the moment and
ultimately transmission and distribution
losses could be improved as well um and
so there's lots of ways we can improve
the efficiency of solar power
should biofuels become widely used
yeah i think there's a lot of interest
in biofuels but
and there's some role for biofuels but i
believe it's limited
i think most of the studies that have
looked at biofuels for energy uh find
that there is a real concern about a
trade-off between agriculture
that is for food supply
and growing crops for for energy and
particularly in emerging markets or in
developing countries one has to be very
careful uh about giving perverse
incentives uh or even in developed
markets in the u.s there are subsidies
for agriculture for things like corn to
create ethanol uh which is a terrible
subsidy uh that distorts food markets
and also leads to sub-optimal energy
markets so i would be very very careful
uh about using biofuels as a big part of
a decarbonization strategy for the world
though in certain parts of the world it
can play a limited role
do electric vehicles actually make a
difference
just getting electric car uh
is just one part of a longer journey if
you plug the electric car into a grid
that's predominantly coal for example in
china
or many other countries around the world
you're not actually doing very much
to enhance sustainability it's still
worth doing the argument goes because
the internal combustion engine which
burns either petrol or diesel
in the case of let's say big lorries is
a dead end you'll never get to zero
carbon on that technology whereas
electric vehicles ultimately could use a
grid that's a zero carbon grid with
renewables and so it's seen as a
leverage point
can heating and air conditioning be made
more sustainable
i mean yes there are alternatives to
uh air conditioners and heaters uh heat
pumps are an example that can be four
times as energy efficient but the bigger
question is how do we actually make
buildings more efficient there's a
terrible problem britain for example is
among the worst housing stock in the uh
in europe but around the world
we often build without much attention
being paid to energy efficiency and if
we start by not needing
so much energy to heat and cool homes
having proper uh triple glazed windows
for example and well-constructed homes
we would actually need less of the heat
and air conditioning to begin with
thank you for watching
to read more about making energy more
sustainable click the link
and don't forget to subscribe
you